all right China China Oh where'd you
grow up where you from originally
Oakland Oakland mm-hmm and tell me about
your family you had both your parents
when you grew up my mom died I died when
I was like seven she died because she my
dad was beating on her to beat her and
he ended up killing her so now he's in
jail for life so really I had to go my
own and do everything on my own
starting at 13 16 now it was three years
you started working the streets at 13
alright harmony and Nina so so about a
month ago harmony
you and I did a little talk here and you
told me your name is China you tell me
some other things and some of those
things you told me weren't we're in a
hundred percent true right well
something that was true so you're
working you're working figure out yeah
but you don't have a 13 year old sister
who's doing this and you're in fact 13
my one sister eight years old no she's
nine years old she get Oh see back at
home I'm not even I'm from Kansas
[Music]
nowhere near Oakland dear from Kansas
what you talking is this eight nine
hours me on a plane so I don't know so
you ran away yeah when did you run away
I started running away back our home in
Wichita which led me here to get away
from running away but then I started
running away out here to get away from
what to get away from to get away from
like all that running away and stuff
that I was doing back at home I had to
come here because it was like my mom
wanted to get me away from stuff that
she knew I was going to keep running how
many likes attention so I thought that
moving her out here to LA with me which
was where I was living at the time you
know we've always had dreams of her
going to the Millenial dance complex and
her dancing with Matt steffanina at that
studio she's a good dancer um yeah she's
a great dancer and so I I went out there
and you know we checked out the studio I
wanted to get her enrolled in that and
we got her signed up at the YMCA
downtown and you know I was just I
spoiled her a lot throughout the time
you know
you came out here she got new everything
and just trying to get hurt not trying
to punish her for her path but trying to
just move on from it and do something
different what made you want to run away
in the first place
attention love I mean not even attention
mm-hmm attention because yeah she works
a lot so it's like as much as she's
worked it's like she not doing it it's
just too you know doing she's doing it
for everything so her kids have somewhat
earlier yeah and I wasn't getting right
until you know I kept running
she kept passing and cried down to me
and tell me and she riders just told me
it would I happened to cry and stuff so
mm-hmm you chose to come home but going
to Los Angeles going to South Central
and working on Figueroa as the
prostitutes a big step from yeah was see
that right there I didn't even know what
all I was until I read oh like I ran
away for a couple of days and I was hey
I was I run away and I went to the ball
wheels Kershaw mom but that's where I
first got my first destination when I
ran away I was my first destination
I went there and I met this
light-skinned girl and we started
hanging out stuffy suits our little she
said it was her uncle house yeah honest
so we we there whatever yeah
but then yeah I think kicked me out
because I kept stealing phones from the
people and stuff and going out and
stealing phones from people so he kicked
me out and then that's when I just
started I met this this dude and I
didn't even know that he was trying to
you know be a pimp he I thought he was
young my boyfriend or something
so it's that's that's how I was thinking
but then when he showed me the blade it
was like my name's easy so I don't know
I just I started to do it
and didn't like it then why why did you
think I mean why didn't you if you need
money you know you can call me why would
you resort to that it wasn't just
learning it was one of my news okay you
gave him your way so it wasn't about was
the attention and it was the socializing
and people I was around that was keeping
me around it not just the money because
I could not make no money all night
no so that's what I was doing most but
are you ready for a thirteen-year-old
girl it's pretty extreme move it is cuz
but I'm gonna learn for me you know
because that's go making a bigger person
yeah well especially cuz I thirteen
how'd that uh sound you're such a you're
such a smart and beautiful girl you have
the whole you know it's so much
potential Allen Tate cuz I you know that
acting idea last time no but staying on
track and doing the right things in life
are gonna helped you do wonderful things
in life and going down there and I'm
doing that if you watch some of the
other girls that have done what you're
doing you see where they end up it's a
it's a tough life and never and I don't
know if there's any that have said yeah
it was a great move and I'm happy I did
it and I've made a lot of money not one
it's not a happy moment it's like every
night you should feel nervous going out
there police driving by you flashy
lights and 13-3 right there is why
and you're not supposed to be out there
cuz you win you did just run from
placement it sounds like and there's
other girls that aged out there right
yeah not a lot not a lot but there's
others they probably lied to they
probably need more in back streets in
out of sight say you guys are going back
to Kansas
yeah Kansas City yes we live and your
harmonies father lives there as well so
you guys would be a happy family again
hopefully trying to get back to that
that'd be great your girl got a little
bit off track a lot of it but you got
her back yeah I'm gonna try since I last
like these three yeah why do you think
that is
cuz montano right that started me um I
started fighting a lot of sick scary and
I started to get him to spend every day
in the sixth grade which led me to I
think he was ayat II and more depression
feeling because I don't like being in
trouble
actually I don't like you know punish me
I'm gonna find my way to get out of
these best as I can I'm say whatever I
got to say to get out of it and if I
don't get out of it that's when I start
to get mad and throw a temper tantrum
but that was before I just thought now I
just run yeah so you were you were on
figure of since way like two months
after I ran away out here that's enough
so that's why quit beginning of the year
you know it's made by May plus he you've
only been working figure off for a short
period it's only like three months three
months even know all about Figaro well
you see you seem very experienced in
that talk though the first video really
only bit off the girl because some of
the other girls that I've interviewed
watched your video and I said oh that
girl's not she's not fresh she's been
around a long time you can tell yeah
that's cuz I'm the good yeah you are
good I told her I was like you had so
many other things to run to in
California this is like the city where
people's dreams come true could have
went in stood in the Hollywood line and
became an actor if that's what she
wanted to do
my main concern with harmony is is what
does she want to do with her life and
how can we start to heal from this and
what can I do so that you don't leave
home again
because I'm a mother I'm always gonna
have to work see working you can work
all you need to make time for me too
what would you like to do with me
anything I don't matter if we gotta
watch TV together which we don't even
watch TV but I'll do it I think kids
just want to be with their parents you
don't need to be going to Disneyland or
anything crazy you just need to just be
with them
talk to them listen got me long go for a
walk just decided for me to feel good
you know my mom right here to here I
haven't watched TV with you I don't
watch TV but I'm sorry
[Music]
but everything I'm good just waiting
probably I seem to make a little video
after this we should do it mean post it
we should do it down the road yeah a
year or whatever you want yeah because I
think you're gonna do great things right
you smell like part 2 this is part 2
Italy maybe part 3 4 or 5 who knows
you're only 13 I had a big pile you do
you're very intelligent
oh my intuition - my my my
craziness - everything else is like a
lot being crazy is nothing that's not
necessarily the worst thing in the world
it's not it's not you can use it as fuel
I do but my money is if I said there's
no more alive I love Zune yeah you said
your mom and dad were dead you said that
yeah my daddy healer
you said you graduated high school I
don't I don't think you have right right
you know instead of various upgrades I'm
in seventh grade
so you're out of school right now so
look I ain't been in school since
coronavirus started
but your mom came out here to get you
people back at home that was going on
placing that video it's crazy because
it's big and it's like I don't know
gonna just like get that many views and
everybody's just gonna come in tourists
are asking me if I'm the girl in the
video like hey you like that though I
like it that they they come into me like
that cause it's attention but I don't
like the why they're coming to me the
reason why you that's reading okay so
you don't like all attention or you do I
don't like on says you because that's
not good attention yeah it's not that's
why I said I was just do this video and
then it be you so who me to respond to
them when they come to me who is your
family then like what do they like
because your dad is known as a
woman-beater right now my dad he never
in my mom is like never ever ever ever
have the closest relationship look cuz
my dad my best friends then did it in
two years they've been together in 10
years your mom your mom my dad split up
yeah they send up on their mobile
assistant but they still live together
right you still we still raise you guys
in the same way this in the same
household and everything but they are
not together they're not together mom
with to go work and travel but your
dad's a good dude huh your dad's a good
guy yeah really did you really I know
your mom cares I know you're mobbed here
that's like that's like my twin in
emotions do dad
that's the way it goes and this is my
20-20-20
fight but I see it you guys look like
yeah my dad is my twin and all my
emotions and life like problems either
do like I can relate to my dad so what
are some things that I have taught you
that you are using when you're out there
I'm not there I'm using my dad solution
what she taught me how to use right she
didn't know I came with my intuition
because she got a good intuition which
came to me and I hope the kids a little
sister too
so who knows and she taught me about a
man to see before I wanted before I
started all this stuff I was I ain't
even other pimp was like I said I didn't
teach you at a pimp was that's why I
said I don't even know what a pimp was
it was about I was thinking more about
boyfriend and men and stuff and she was
telling me well a boyfriend isn't really
you know talk to you that a boy is a boy
inside you pay attention to not your
date
yeah not I day a man is something and
grow and fill it and last wait and I can
but I feel like that's kind of it's not
the same thing but what I just said okay
I'll talk to you boys are something you
pay attention to nobody wants to date a
boy you can't do nothing for you
a man is someone who you will practice
where you'll go through relationships
you will practice with men and the king
is someone who you will build and grow
with and marry and have children with
yeah now you know what a pimp is though
that that ain't no man I mean Kenai and
a boyfriend that's just like us to lean
before to be honest like he's making
money off of little girls I'm telling
you whatever you want to hear to make
you feel good not even some little girls
oh me too that's why I get beat on
because they keep going back cuz it's
tough that that pimp tell them they're
gonna keep on that cuz they so special
and that's one thing I'm not stupid I
mean even if I was older doing so when
we go home are you going to run away
from me again I plan on staying even
when it gets hard like when it get hard
I'm gonna be in it um being activity
sign know when it get hard and yell I
mean I'm gonna just be able to go do my
track he's gonna be all over no I'm done
what I'm done with dealing I've learned
how to control my emotions since you've
been gone
because yelling doesn't get you to come
home so I have to I had to learn how to
control my emotions and stuff so it's
not gonna be no reason for me to run I'm
being tried dance whatever I ought to be
able track and dance the same
team sounds like it's all about up well
not only are you gonna be injured hey
you're on the track team - oh he's
slashing I can easily go back when I
going on
I have things set up for her back at
home like you know I love rattling yes
there's a black-owned Network back at
home and they have a television studio
they have a podcast situation they have
a radio station and a studio so she
likes to do music so she's gonna do that
she's gonna get back involved in sports
and I'm also gonna be starting a podcast
with her teaching her about spirituality
her spirituality how to be self aware of
who she is and why she does the things
she does how emotions how to control her
thoughts entrepreneurship and just life
as a whole because I don't want other
children to go through what she did and
had I known that my job I'm I'm a hair
stylist so I travelled to do hair had I
known that it was affecting her the way
that it did would you think everybody
was telling you that but it's just you
didn't really understand it was just
like I'm working I don't know there's a
reason sometimes I still don't
understand because I feel like I leave
for a couple of days to go work while
other parents work three two and three
jobs and have to be gone every day from
their children but this dream is though
that colors behind the army that go and
be living their children for a year at a
time and their family is at home
supporting them and their kids are not
leaving there's there's there's um the
flight attendants they're gone from
their children 24 hours at a time
there's a lot of people who work that
have to to leave even even here like he
just reporters he just right
he just wasn't gone and you know all
parents we have to work lights and I
mean I mean but you it's the thing is
you have to look at things you have to
learn how to find the positive and
things and look at things in a positive
perspective although yes your mama works
but she's been close to coast you've
seen both both oceans you ate on the
beach I was traveling a lot of things
I've been with my mom while she tribal
dishes when she leaves in it it's like
dang it just yeah not every time you can
go I want to be a woman and that's what
I feel like so in this light I can't be
with her and I get so used to can't be
aware her I just feel like you know
being on my own like she do and just
like I just feel like that's what she's
doing but it I want so that's how I was
thinking and that's why I be running
you're very mature 13-year old so it's
almost like you're more like a 16 year
old or something
you actually can think for yourself I
think it attention awake at the end of
the day we have to have self-love and if
you're constantly seeking attention from
others and seeking love from others
you're not going to be focused on loving
yourself and giving yourself attention
because you paying attention to yourself
is way more important than anybody else
paying attention to you know when I pay
attention to myself the most I pay
attention to myself is when I'm going to
run that's the most when I pay attention
to myself my home I'm really I'm
depending to myself but I do but I don't
cuz it's like I'm too busy
cuz home is where everybody's at so it's
like I'd be too busy worried about
friends and I'm I'm now about not myself
I'm talking about in general no matter
where you are you need to be paying
attention to yourself loving yourself
not worried about who else is paying
attention to you like why why do you
care so much about what others see is it
social media that's making you like that
I care so much about what I see cuz a
lot of people because of how I am a lot
of people know me so and that's where
most of my attention comes from so John
lose all eyes like damn the most of your
dumb little yourself yeah most of my
attention should go for myself and I'm
can we go words on me yeah your mom's
advice is very good loving yourself to
solve about 20 other problem well we can
work on it together yeah cuz I'm not
perfect either
yeah you're started with this for the
rest of your life she last some years to
go to and you're only 13 so you have
plenty of time to change and you have
plenty of time to grow especially how
much I know now my girl girl just use it
to the best of your use it we gotta use
it music all right Nina
harmony yeah thank you so much for
coming back and explaining everything
that really was going on and did like
getting back to Kansas City and good
luck if your your future I mean you're
you're an amazing girl you're beautiful
you're smart you're talented it would be
such a waste that you went back to that
lifestyle this is a waste of time
there's so many better ways to live yeah
plenty of the ways to find happiness and
attention thanks you guys
you
you